the southeast face is dangerous
conditions this morning even after the
storm moved on roads from Florida to
North Carolina are coated in snow and
ice after freezing cold overnight
drivers are being urged to avoid
unnecessary travel Manuel Bojorquez is
in Savannah Georgia where the
temperature is stuck below freezing and
well good morning good morning we are at
the foot of Savannah's iconic Talmadge
bridge which is shut down due to ice as
are many other bridges and overpasses
like this wood right here it is hard to
walk on these streets let alone drive
and many haven't been treated because
they simply don't have the resources
here it is so cold that an Amtrak train
partly slipped off the tracks last night
when the switches froze visibility and
slick highways caused hundreds of
drivers to spin out across the south
heavy snow and freezing temperatures the
blasted states from Florida to the
Carolinas stay home stay off the roadway
at all cost more than five inches of
snow were recorded in Charleston making
it the city's third snowiest day on
record everyone is completely freaking
out as you can see the town shut down
more than an inch of snow blanketed
Savannah Georgia on the city streets
police helped get traffic moving and
back in the right direction this is
crazy
raven night said she's never experienced
anything like this
rare sight in Tallahassee Florida where
the city saw its first snowfall in 28
years and so the concern now going
forward is the wind and ice could lead
to more power outages in Georgia alone
more than 9,000 people are without power
right now temperatures are expected to
crawl into the 40s but they will remain
below average for a large part of the
southeast through the weekend
Jeff all right Manny thanks